this marvel multiverse event spanning
from one division to spider-man 3
and multiverse of madness is gonna
reboot the mcu
with its new avenger lineup with heroes
from alternate realities ryan reynolds
deadpool
a new wolverine captain britain squirrel
girl
and god willing a cameo by robert downey
jr as an alternate anthony stark
sorcerer supreme
[Music]
all right everybody tonight it's time to
take things very seriously welcome back
to new rock stars
doctor strange is opening up portals in
spider-man 3
and who's that peeking through why
that's eric voss and our other great
guests
i am tommy bechtold and this is rogue
theory
the show that brings you the wildest
nerdy hot takes on the topics you can't
stop arguing about
with me today is new rock star's own
sorcerer supreme
eric voss what's up eric hi everybody i
lost my sling ring so if you can look
around in the sand
and uh at every beach and if you could
let me know if you find it i
will pay up to uh ten dollars for it ah
yes i love it returning guest writer
laura sirikou
hey laura how are you
gonna be here uncle tommy we're so happy
to have you my darling niece
and finally friend of the show comedian
erica wuzu what's up eric
hey it's erica wilson back again and
ready to rogue the rogueist of rogue
episode of rogue theory
rogues that's right and this episode as
always is in honor of josh allen and the
buffalo bills who are bravely taking on
the tennessee titans against all odds
later on today what will be two days
when this finally airs the magic of the
internet alive before you
time travel is real folks let's go to
the future
every day brings more crazy news from
the set of spider-man three first we
found out jamie foxx was coming back his
electro
now we hear that dr strange is joining
the party upcoming marvel titles like
juan division and dr strange ii
multiverse of madness
are going to explore the idea of
alternate universe versions of the
reality
we know in the mcu so gang besides
electro getting a reboot
what other existing mcu characters could
get rebooted through the use of the
multiverse
in spider-man 3. eric uh eric voss let's
start with you
okay um so i don't know i think
throughout marvel's rescheduling
it's interesting that they it seems like
they've reconfigured the release order
so that
one division is now coming first right
and then dr strange and the multiverse
of madness
is now slid back so that it's coming
after these other titles
i think that was like a blessing in
disguise for marvel because i think
that's exactly how they want it to go
because now
we're also saying how doctor strange is
going to appear in spider-man 3
and we've known that wanda is going to
come back in multiverse of madness it
seems like they're these like
these cross thwips that are going on so
that all of this
is linked and what is looking like a
multi-title crossover event
culminating in multiverse of madness
beginning with one division
this marvel multiverse event spanning
from one division to spider-man
3 and multiverse of madness is going to
reboot the mcu
with its new avenger lineup with heroes
from alternate realities ryan reynolds
deadpool
a new wolverine captain britain squirrel
girl and
god willing a cameo by robert downey jr
as an alternate anthony stark sorcerer
i don't think we've ever properly
scrutinized how weird kevin feige's
phase four pitch was at the beginning
like characters were being pitched as
legacies
at the same time that it sounds like
most of the main cast is sticking around
so like black widow appears to be
setting up yelling at bolova right but
the trailer features natasha saying
stuff in direct contradiction to her
final chapter talk and end game and then
jane foster's gonna be wielding mjolnir
but chris hemsworth has said that thor 4
won't be his last movie
and also mjolnir's destroyed how is she
wielding it
uh there's just a lot of these
indicators suggesting each of these
phase four titles will be
set in alternate universes within a
multiverse that i believe will be
shattered by
one division i believe those universes
will web together in spider-man 3
in a kind of spider-verse crisis that
i've talked about in another video
but the real epic convergence will be in
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness see
there have been unconfirmed reports
suggesting that ryan reynolds might be
signing a huge deal with marvel studios
even if that's not real it's probably so
that's going to happen
uh very soon i also recently swung hard
on a theory that
free guy could secretly be a crossover
revealing that ryan reynolds
game avatar is the one identity noob
master 69 the fortnite handle
that i think is gonna be wade wilson in
the mcu someday
now we also keep hearing more and more
about rumors that marvel wants their new
wolverine as
a true animalistic anti-hero that he is
in the comics
uh and we've all speculated from
everyone from taryn edgerton to keanu
reeves playing this character
uh some people are saying shia labeouf
i'm not saying that but others are
uh there's all kinds of amazing options
they could go hugh jackman said he's
done with it but
i'm i'm so excited to see what they're
gonna do with wolverine
uh and then also avengers end game gave
a little nod to captain britain remember
with peggy carter's line where she
mentioned someone named braddock who was
delayed by lightning at camp lehi and
yeah it's sounding more and more likely
that a squirrel girl title is in
development
but the reason i bring up all those
characters they all sound like kind of
bonkers weirdos who come from other
parts of the multiverse rather than ones
that exist
in this world currently so assuming
scarlet witch is going to be the villain
of multiverse of madness like her chaos
magic causing all of reality to flicker
uncontrollably
the moment strange successfully
confronts her i think the
no more mutants moment will collapse all
of reality into one
shared universe with all these oddballs
from other dimensions all living
together
but in the midst of that madness i'm
gonna go back to this i think we have to
include at least a small cameo by robert
downey jr
even if it's just like his face via
archive footage digitally like dragged
and dropped
onto a cgi body as an alternate reality
sorcerer supreme just because marvel
has already rendered that visual of tony
stark in the cloak of levitation in
concept art
for infinity war i think it's time we
see it for real in
this crossover event yes eric
pretty ricky voss throwing his fastball
at 99 miles an hour
to begin i love it i loved every element
of that i
i felt like i could visualize all of it
you used great use of
web puns during your spider-man pitch
and of course
who does not want to see robert downey
jr come back
even though we only just lost him one
movie ago in that
it's still from the second that tony
stark died and they had that funeral
scene
i immediately started fantasizing about
ways for him to come back so
i uh won't award you any rogies because
i'm not giving out the rogies in this
episode
to give up the roggies in this episode
will be none other than my childhood
bear and terrifying nightmare
super teddy uh who is missing one eye
because he dated kate blanchette and she
got a little too method when preparing
for uh
for thor 3. so uh she she she got uh she
took his eye out super teddy who
believes in truth justice in the
american way
has awarded you two rogies for your
[Music]
thank theory super teddy you are welcome
i don't know why he talks like that uh
regretting that
regretted that instantly we'll see if he
has another voice for laura laura what
do you got for me
okay so so in doctor strange's he's able
to go through different multiverses we
all know this
and we all know all the movies have been
pushed back especially one that
we have been waiting for for a long time
and that is
black widow poor black widow
gets killed off in endgame only to have
her
solo movie that we've been waiting for
over 10 years
for her to have is push back again
so because of the spiderman news and we
want to
hype up black widow because we've been
she's been screwed over
over and over and over
and over again and one more time over
again so in order to kind of even that
out we're gonna have a black widow make
an appearance to kind of prepare
for and what she's old and also to kind
of prepare for the movies that's coming
out or even after
it comes out before but it's also to
give continue the hype
um and not only is it black widow it's
going to be
yelena's black widow ah because
okay we know um natasha died um and
yelena
is none other than the world's
national treasure like the world
treasure international
so everyone's gonna love her and even
she said
you will see more of yelena if
if the movie is done well if the movie
everyone loves her in the movie
which we will because it's lawrenceburg
so therefore
they're gonna have to they're gonna have
a continuation of her
in spiderman just so we could get the
hype going because we have black widow
yes the movie and then
i predict in the end she's gonna join
the
the avengers anyway like at the end of
black widow like he's gonna be like i
heard my sister died
i can't do a russian accent but she said
she says i should come in there
so in order to kind of do that we'll
open like
doctor strange is gonna present her as
well as the black widow because
time has gone by so we get to see her be
introduced as the new black widow in the
avengers because in the end of black
widow we see her
like she will see her come in as i'm
like
like you know come to find her sister
and then in spider-man
we'll introduce her as black widow so
that's nice theory that we're gonna have
like we're gonna like go on and like
have her
be the new face so we have her
introduced in black widow the movie
spider-man black uh yelena as black
widow
i love it love it wonderful yes
uh i i am on board with that as well i
believe you are right uh
international i'll say galactic treasure
florence
pure how am i saying that right fort
pierre i have no idea how to say your
last name
florence this whole time so florence
pewdiepie
foreign florence pew
yeah lock her down for like nine movies
she's great uh
i uh i laura i was set to give you two
rogies but super teddy says russian
accents make him scared because he's
very xenophobic
so he's only giving you one rogie for
your theory
oh my god is it converting to something
or no
uh you know i forgot to do that for eric
and in the interest of uh
shaming him yeah it could turn into
whatever you want oh look
you gave me a booth but not only a boot
it's a boot that has iron man in it
an iron man i think that pun deserves
another one but yeah
that's a that's a wishing boot right
there
the coops given year round wonderful
wonderful all right
erica wuzu you're gonna bring us home
what do you got yeah
here i come okay so here's my rogue
theory
uh my rogue theory involves one of
hollywood's most notorious rogues ever
none other than nicholas cage
what i think that the mcu
will incorporate nicholas cage beloved
thespian yes
uh and have him reprise his role as
ghost writer i think she's gonna
ride that fiery motorcycle right into
the mcu yes
via one division because in the comic
books
ghost rider uh the one we're most
familiar with is a guy named johnny
blaze yeah
who nicholas cage played in the beloved
we'll call them beloved movies uh back
in the day
he was given his powers by mephisto
uh he was a wizard demon type person uh
johnny blaise had to
sacrifice himself to save his father in
the comic books made a deal with the
devil
bonded his soul with the demon through
mephisto to become
fire skull headed yes ghost rider towel
as old as time yeah
oldest time right next to the garden of
eden
so yeah uh mephisto is rumored to be
part of juan division as maybe a villain
or or enter the mcu
in some place way shape or form coming
up and it's probably going to be played
by
evan peters who played quicksilver on
fox's x-men movies
so mephisto will probably come into the
air so ghost rider will have some sort
of conflict some sort of mystical
magical
hand-waving spell casting battle
with uh doctor strange and juan division
and whatever whatever
other mystics they want to throw into
the mix because everything's insane
everyone's being introduced to
the marvel cinematic universe yeah so
ghost writer is coming in
i think it's going to be nicholas cage
or i'm hoping i'm saying it out loud so
that the execs that watch this show
can pick that and make it happen uh
and i think in terms of connecting it
with spider-man 3
and all the insanity and spider-verse
characters we'll see
come back into this live-action version
we'll probably be doing with tom holland
i think that spider-man noir is going to
be one of the many spider-mans
that are going to be in the next
spider-man movie
i think ghost rider played by nicholas
cage and
spider-man noir also played by nicholas
cage are going to have a
face sauce
scream at each other shut it down some
way shape or form in the mcu coming up
maybe you want to visit spiderman three
we'll see we'll find out but that's my
rogue theory
oh my gosh play ghost rider and
spiderman noir wow big swing
one cage is enough two cages
is an embarrassment of riches we're
getting johnny blaze and spider who
aren't well for me
personally i'd give you a million rogies
but let's see what super teddy has to
say
come on super teddy uh what's that oh
super teddy says he's a big nicholas
cage fan and he's giving you
three rookies
[Music]
thanks okay give me all the rogies
yes uh if nicholas cage appears even
once
i will be delighted but if he appears
twice as two different characters
and those characters talk to each other
i don't know what i'll do you'll have to
lock me in a vault for a few weeks so i
can cool down
but uh just give me lots of gatorades
he's a natural treasure oh
god how dare you
all right city of angels it's gonna be
hotter than
arizona when you see nick cage get out
of here
all right okay gone in 60 seconds
speaking of
let's pay some bills guys i want to talk
to you about jingle jangle jingle jangle
i'm not singing a song
you can't sue me for public usage this
song doesn't exist
ah the holiday season is right around
the corner and this year
we know that people will be buying more
stuff online than ever it's amazon prime
day today for crying out loud i've
already worked up a sweat with my thumbs
more so than usual on a tuesday anyway
if you're an e-commerce seller are you
ready to meet the demands of a
record-breaking online shopping season i
bet you're not
coward so listen to me and i will lead
you to the promised land
be ready with ship station shipstation
cell helps online sellers of any size
get orders out quickly save money on
shipping and keep customers happy and as
i always
say on this show eric you can back me up
on this a happy customer
is a returning customer and a sad
customer is someone who shops at walmart
they'll get you the shipping rates
normally reserved for fortune 500
companies we're talking the big ones
we're talking uh farmersonly.com we're
talking
uh rallies fast food the p the bigwigs
all the big earners
people that have been succeeding forever
we're talking uh gnc
supplement company hertz rent-a-car
famously out of business this year but
they get the shipping rates okay you
want to play like hertz you want to bat
with the big boys use ship station
it's the fastest easiest most affordable
way to manage and ship your orders
just a few clicks and you'll be managing
your orders and getting your product
to happy customers which as we know
means they will come back to you if you
love a customer
make them happy if they come back to you
they're yours
if they don't they're idiots okay
shipstation
works with all major carriers and their
interface brings the products together
whether you're selling them on
etsy amazon or your own website i
personally have a website you know
tommy's slugs and bugs
where i will ship you exotic animals
illegally anywhere in the united states
shipstation is the number one choice of
online sellers you'll ship more and less
time
with the best rates available and now
rogue theory listeners can try
shipstation free for 60 days
when you use the offer code rogue make
sure your business is ready to meet the
demands of
a massive online shopping season get
started at shipstation.com today
click on that little microphone at the
top of the homepage and type in
rogue that's shipstation.com then enter
the offer code
rogue shipstation.com
make ship happen happen
now it's time to talk about something
near and dear to my heart your balls
folks
listen up fellas because today we have a
new manscape product alert
manscape just released the weed whacker
nose and ear trimmer which is very
counterintuitive to how i began this
because we're not talking about balls
today we're talking about noses and ears
head shoulders knees and toes all
important to shave but none more so than
your nose and ears take a look in the
mirror
and i guarantee you'll see hair sticking
out of those holes you sickos
it's time to keep your ear and nose hair
looking as
good as the other clean shaven parts of
your body think about me i'm like a baby
newborn seal
it's all clear down there guys some
would even say translucent
some women have said how are you so pale
as a bearded and mustachio gentleman i
like facial hair
but i don't want that facial hair to
continue up past the lip limit into my
nostrils
79 of partners pulled say that long nose
hair is a major turn off and guess what
the other
21 are lying because their long-haired
nosed boyfriends
are sensitive and they don't want to
hurt their feelings because that's a 100
issue guys we are bipartisan in nose
hair being gross
and i'm not ready to pull those bad boys
out for hand life is painful enough
already have you ever accidentally
plucked a nose hair
it almost hurts worse than getting
kicked in the other place your manscaper
works
manscaped is forever changing the
grooming game with their weed whacker
the nose and ear trimmer provides
proprietary skin safe technology which
help
which help which helps prevent knicks
snags and tugs in those delicate holes
all your holes should never be snagged
or tugged guys
if someone's tugging at a hole of yours
don't be their friend
don't bring them over to your house
anymore don't do improv with them and
certainly don't be in a relationship
with them no one tugs a hole if they
love you
okay the manscape weed whacker uses 9000
rpms
360 degree rotary dual blade system with
a contour design to enhance the trimming
experience i've said for years my
trimming experience needed enhancements
why is my trimming experience so mundane
why is it so boring the people at
manscape have answered my prayers
it's waterproof so it's easy to use and
clean and it has a rechargeable battery
that lasts up to 90 minutes and i would
like to reiterate
if you are trimming your nose or ears
for 90 minutes there is something wrong
with your body
it should probably take 10 to 15 maximum
it's time to upgrade
your manscaped routine with the weed
whacker get 20
off and free shipping with the code
rogue theory at manscape.com
that's 20 off with free shipping at
manscape.com
use code rogue theory what are you
waiting for
go whack those weeds whack your weeds go
whack your weeds yeah let's get wacky
and finally let's talk about something
that's never been a problem for me
but boy oh boy is it a problem for some
of our listeners just kidding
this episode is also sponsored by blue
chew something that has saved my life
and if i was married would definitely be
necessary like billy butcher
reconnecting with becca in the back of
an suv
we could all use better sex in our lives
right now i'll tell you what
is that true or any sex uh well now you
can increase your performance and get
the extra confidence in bed and god
knows do i need it i am so shy in bed
i'll tell you what i'm like a little
daffodil just in need of blooming
blue chew brings you the first chewable
with the same fda approved
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
so if you're big enough to have sex but
still a scared little boy about pills
you can chew this one
you can take them any time day or night
even on a full stomach eat a rack of
ribs and then take a blue tube
roll the dice with that god knows what a
fun evening that'll be
so you can be ready whenever an
opportunity arises blue chew is
made in the usa it's prescribed online
by licensed physicians
so you don't have to go to the doctor or
wait in line or go see some guy in an
alleyway who promises to get you hard
no questions asked because that is never
fun guys see a medical professional
it's even cheaper than a pharmacy and
they prepare and ship it right to you in
a discreet package but as i say i wish
they would
ship it in an indiscreet package a
howler from the harry potter universe
announcing
boner alert boner alert this boy about
to get sprung
okay no awkwardness and you don't need
to leave the house
if you could benefit from more
confidence where it counts and i bet you
can jeremy
blue chew is the fast and easy way to
enhance your performance
right now we've got a special deal for
our listeners visit bluetooth.com
and get your first shipment free when
you use our special promo code
rogue just pay five dollar shipping
again that's b
l u e chew dot com promo code rogue to
try it
for free blue chew is the better cheaper
choice
and we thank them for sponsoring the
show and remember when you support our
sponsors you help make this podcast
possible
so please be sure to use our promo code
rogue
bluetooth.com
eric remember let's say the bluetooth
phrase together
it's hard in here okay guys now it's
time for our discord
rogue theory quick shout out to our
patron kenzie
aka galactic gal who won this week's
discord rogue theory with an awesome
pitch for a shirley chisholm biopic
starring lupita yongo yes on the new
rockstars discord we have people pitch
rogue theories for historical biopics
starring mcu actors we love it if you
need the world to hear your idea for
jeremy renner as william henry harrison
movie
become a patron by going to patreon.com
new rockstars speaking of creatively
reimagining
uh american history let's move on to
topic number two
the boys season three soldier boy
that's what we're talking here guys the
boys season two just wrapped up on
amazon prime last week spoiler warning
if you haven't finished it yet
eric voss and i covered the season
episode by episode on the boys
underground
with our friend marina mastros here on
the channel so go check that out
but show runner eric kripke has said
some really interesting quotes that have
us
buzzing z hear that swatto buzzing about
season three i'm gonna get swatto in
this show whether we have to write them
in
ourselves in fan films or just justify
that fly that keeps landing on edible
arrangements in the show all right
so he has said that the recently cast
jensen ackles
will be playing the comics character
soldier boy in the comics soldier boy
was a captain america ripoff that
desperately wanted to be a member of the
seven though kripke has said that the
show version
and the team he leads payback were the
seven before the seven in in the tv
universe so
my question for you three knowing that
the show often makes big changes to
comic characters to fit better
into its universe what is the season
three version of soldier boy going to be
like
and how will he impact the seven and the
boys
eric uh wussu why don't you go first hey
here we go
so with season three the boys which i'm
still reeling from the end of season two
of the boys
i had exploded with that ending
see what happened with uh representative
newman
uh so i think this iteration of soldier
boy played by janice and ankles
uh will be a superhero who's fame hungry
but also
steals homelanders spotlight as the
all-american friendly superhero
because soldier boy in the comics is
very pretty much like a
pseudo captain america he's like
rah-rah-rah
valor honor justice talks with the 40s
twang in his
addiction um and so since he's such a
boy scout
i think he will favor uh victoria newman
uh
being all about the government and
america and america over
vaught i think he will be so
disillusioned and so easily controlled
by vaught
uh that he'll lean more towards victoria
newman and newman will favor
working with him to try to use him as a
puppet to try to get more into vlogs in
her workings and to get on homelanders
nerves
which is real easy to do because he's
very easily manipulated because he's a
giant dangerous child super baby
so i think that would be the main thing
of season three they'll use soldier boy
as like a chess piece
against each other of newman and
homelander
um and the audience will be on pins and
needles the whole time waiting on
someone's head to go pop like a
birthday balloon yes love it uh i
i very much enjoy uh having a kind of
like kiss assy
uh like uh try like trying to curry
favor i also think there's gonna be a
huge opening of homelanders acting very
erratically as we kind of saw towards
the end of the season for someone to
kind of step
in if he makes a bunch of high-profile
faux pas he's going to kind of step in
and steal his thunder so
since we are in such agreement and super
teddy who is also a homelander wannabe
uh loved that theory he has decided to
award you two
rogies yes yes two
yeah two rogies all right uh who's going
next voss what do you got
all right um so when we were talking
about the uh season finale
uh i pointed out how homelanders son
ryan you know how he's listing us states
to calm himself and we were talking
about how that's
pretty similar to the way soldier boy in
the comics lists the u.s states as a
kind of battle cry when he's like
mid-battle
i think there might be a link there so
uh homelander
never knew his father right that keeps
coming up we've explored his mommy
issues haven't really explored his daddy
issues
i'm wondering if the genetic material
that was used to create homelander might
have come
from soldier boy and if he is a captain
america analog
he might have been cryogenically frozen
from the world war ii era he could be
another ageless soup
like uh liberty who became stormfront
was but like because the americans are
trying to copy the german technology
uh and vaught hadn't really maybe been
behind us that's version of soldier boys
um creation maybe he was like a
malfunctioning one so he's not as
efficient
as storefront is uh so maybe we're
exploring this family tree of soldier
boy and homelander and ryan maybe each
generation
designed to check the power of the
former uh and i can imagine like
homelander and soulja boy getting along
great at first now playing some catch
but like i
i would want to see that uh that
cryogenic
flaw starting to break down his body and
he's like decomposing disgustingly he's
just like
coughing up organs and stuff and maybe
he devises this plot to like try to
harvest organs from homelander and ryan
in order to
like in the mummy to kind of plug back
into his body
so that he can be immortal uh i just
want to see it start out as something
sweet that like homelander feels like
finally he's cured because he has his
father figure that he never had
but then like everything else in his
world it disappoints him
as it turns on him and then it's just
going straight to this [ __ ] yes
yeah yeah yeah i love it eric uh for
reminding me that there's no better
superhero than a soupsicle
who's been frozen in time and also for
making me think of the classic mel
gibson banger forever young
when he plays a man frozen who gets
unfrozen and then begins to rapidly age
and fall apart both i and super teddy
award you
three rogy
three rogies i'll be uh i'll be enjoying
those in the form of cocktails that i'll
drink while i watch mel gibson steal a
government plane and fly to an island
and turn into an old man who probably
croaks right as the credits are finished
yes yes absolutely santa claus in that
one
yes he will soon be seen as santa claus
uh
good good call laura speaking of good
calls what is your theory
okay so we know uh soldier boy he was
he's mentioned and shown in
the boys in the last season so what
i'm using evidence from quotes from
cripty
so in the comments he's mostly a
bubbling and subservient
as uh to homelander so they're writing
him to be more
like john wayne john wayne he's one of
those guys and like
he also says he's one of those guys
that's been around for decades of boy
avoids history and he was homeland
before homelander
so he's from a different area uh era but
he's got the
ego and ambition but but it comes across
a different way because he's from a
different time
so if you know how john wayne even
though he's like a acting legend
he also is a guy who believes in white
supremacy yeah
he's an [ __ ] yeah so we we kind of
if they are willing to go far with
stormfront being a nazi
racist person i wouldn't be surprised
that
that we they they get soldier boy to be
kind of be a proud boy mega guy
where oh sure he's willing to move like
creepy is willing to right
this level so i feel like we're gonna
see a mega
pro boy kind of guy who's like like he's
cool with black people or
an asian as long as they stay in their
place so i feel like and i don't think
he's gonna kill them and all that stuff
like storm front was like
racist he's just believes in white
people being better so he
so i feel like he's gonna be a less
extreme like
he's still horrible but like like less
than like so in front of killing them
so i feel like he's gonna be sexist
because that's the era of that time
and he's going to be racist at that era
of the time too
so i feel like we're going to see him
get along with everyone like haha
like oh cool like homelander and but
we're gonna see him kind of be dominant
and be like
you know a proud boy and maggot i feel
like we're gonna see that kind of
uh relationship that he has a homelander
where homelanders gonna be like oh i'm
jealous
but also they're gonna be buddy buddies
but you know it's going to end up badly
well i i will say for for me and for
super teddy
you you hit the nail on the head is that
this show does a great job of kind of
ripping
cultural and uh and news where the
events and headlines
and repurposing them through the eyes of
this uh superhero corporation so both
super teddy and i award you
three rookies for your theory
thank you and the rogie came out to be a
fly the fly
from the boys oh swaddle wait is it also
the fly on mike pence because look it
has a
politicized fly that's gonna go bad in
the comments folks
you people being like i like this show
till the fly came out
anyway uh i don't care
so uh pretty close match up here
uh and we that will bring us to the
rogue question
which will decide our winner today and
it's a banger guys this question is
going to straight up
draw the performances out of three of my
favorite performers
giant theater chain amc has said that
they expect to run out of money by the
end of the year which is sad for movie
fans
and really sad that we've done nothing
to help them can you give
a voice over in the style of the 90s
movie trailer voice don lafontaine
in the world for the disaster movie that
is 2020.
okay in a world
where wearing a mask literally makes you
a superhero
and not wearing one makes you a
conspiracy theorist
tides will turn danger will heighten
and the ending can only be described as
a blindfolded crapshoot
2020. this decade can't get any worse
damn it hey yeah it can oh
god oh god that's so sad but true great
job great job
in a world when the worst virus to hit
the planet in a century
forces everyone to stay home who is the
worst victim
amc cinemas families are realizing they
can save a fortune
staying in friday nights to stream
movies
in their homes they can buy candy and
popcorns from a grocery store
they don't have to the [ __ ] who were
born after 9 11 to just wait 90 minutes
to refresh their instagrams
so they could find zero notifications
anyway you sons of [ __ ]
well they don't have to worry about that
anymore putting us in apocalypse
and in this doomsday scenario who
will rise i know octogenarian
wine cellar and director of robin
williams shack
francis ward coppola he
he and his buddy marty scorsese
are america's last hope to save
cinema from the jokers and the iron boys
they're kicking open the doors of
congress
wearing no masks and they're demanding a
bailout baby
aoc wants to tack on a covered relief a
package amendment
a wine burp jim jordan
this is an arby's i'm almost done
i'm not finished because jim jordan
wants to wrestle you in a bathroom
all alone look out here comes slow
moving irishman
bobby de niro tapping in his body's 30
but his mind's 90
and he's got nipples greg you want to
milk him
20 20 engines
[Music]
did i go too long no no that was perfect
okay here's my deep chade voice all
right
okay in a world where terrorism
knows no boundaries and the level of
threat knows no limits
where all your favorite movies are
pushed back or on streaming now
to die and you can't eat inside your
favorite restaurant
or see your friend that just hung out at
the beach
where fear has a name and a beer company
is pretty pissed off about it
the crew on that virus a mask
coming soon to your face near you 20
20. no it's been pushed back probably 20
or 2022. whenever the whenever the
vaccine comes out
oh my god uh all three of you did a
fantastic job that was great
uh but for the sheer packing in of
references like a kevin smith movie i
have to give
eric voss the win today eric you are our
winner
yeah i win boy king wins mine has a mine
has a title page though
oh that was great great job great job
great job eric as our winner you do get
to request or wish one thing into the
universe what will it be
um i just want all of us to um to just
altogether let out our um existential
whales of despair just let it all out
everything that you've been bottling up
inside everything that you're feeling
just scream it out into the cosmos
everyone ready three
two do it at home two one
i feel so much better and i love doing
it with all of you
that's great that's it for this episode
of rogue theory
thank you to our guests laura eric and
eric you are all
wonderful don't forget to subscribe to
the rogue theory podcast feed and stay
tuned to the youtube channel for this
and other shows
follow these fine people at their
handles follow us
on twitter at new rockstars you follow
your boy anywhere he goes because he
will lead you to the promised land
let's go buffalo josh ellen all the way
you're gonna be really happy when this
video comes out or really sad
i'm gonna be eating these words that's
for sure
[Music]
so
you